[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présentent le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
Marc Philippe d'brez bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sénateur les
républicains du Nord et Nathalie de l
bonjour merci d'être là sénatrice RDSE
de la Gironde on va parler avec vous des
annonces d'Emmanuel Macron sur la
sécurité en milieu rural plus de 200
brigades de gendarmerie réparties sur
l'ensemble du territoire alors est-ce la
bonne réponse vous nous direz ce que
vous en pensez et puis Alex on va
revenir sur la 5e élection de Gérard
Larché à la tête du Sénat effectivement
Gérard Larché réélu hier sur un plateau
on en parle tout de suite dans ce
Scade et on commence avec la réélection
de jérardch Alex Gérard Larché qui a
donc été réélu à la présidence du Sénat
une réélection on peut le dire
confortable on peut le dire Orian le
sénateur les républicains des Yvelines a
été réélu à la tête de la Haute
Assemblée au premier tour hier lors de
cette élection avec 218 voix c'est un
peu moins qu'il y a 3 ans où il avait
récolté 231 voix mais nettement
au-dessus des autres candidats hier à
savoir les trois présidents de groupes
politiqu de gauche au Sénat le président
du Sénat Gerard Larcher qui a notamment
bénéficié de l'abstention du groupe
Renaissance et puis Jard Larcher a été
réélu à cette fonction pour la 5e fois
mais c'est toujours la même émotion
écoutez 5e fois élu à ce poste qu'est-ce
que personnellement vous vous êtes dit
que j'avais le même enthousiasme que la
première fois le même désir et j'allais
dire le même bonheur et
que la 5e fois c'est comme la première
fois c'est une responsabilité que je
reçois par la confiance de mes collègues
alors dans son discours devant les 347
autres sénateurs euh Gérard Larcher a
tenu compte de la situation
parlementaire actuelle dans le pays et
du nouveau rôle joué par le Sénat on
écoute en ces temps où l'équilibre
institutionnel a été profondément
modifié du fait de l'absence de majorité
à l'Assemblée nationale où le fait
majoritaire n'est plus le Sénat a un
rôle essentiel dans le fonctionnement de
nos
institutions il est parvenu à être le
point d'équilibre d'une démocratie à la
peine c'est donc aujourd'hui pour nous
une responsabilité supplémentaire et
pour la première fois d'ailleurs
réellement depuis
1958 et puis Jard Larché s'est également
projeté sur une future réforme des
institutions que pourrait annoncer le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron Emmanuel Macron qui aura besoin
du soutien du Sénat pour toucher à notre
Constitution nous sommes prêts à
envisager toute réforme qui serait utile
à l'amélioration du fonctionnement de
notre démocratie si elle permet de recou
de le pays si elle permet au peuple de
retrouver la confiance en ses
parlementaires ses gouvernants sa
justice mais je le dis je le redis notre
Constitution ne se modifie pas en
fonction des pulsions du moment et puis
enfin on peut retenir que le président
de la Haute Assemblée a demandé à
l'exécutif plus de liberté d'action pour
les collectivités territoriales c'est un
combat de longue date au Sénat les
sénateurs qui ont fait des propositions
au gouvernement pour redonner du souffle
à nos territoires et Gérard Larché
espère bien qu'elles seront entendu
ouais ça fait partie des lignes du
discours de Gérard Larcher on va revenir
peut-être sur deux grandes lignes à la
fois les territoires et puis sa sa
vision de la loi et de l'institution
d'abord sur les territoires Nathalie
delat le président du Sénat l'a dit nous
devons remettre les maires au cœur de la
décision c'était important de délivrer
ce message au gouvernement on l'imagine
oui bien sûr de tout manière c'est
toujours important de recontextualiser
le rôle du du Sénat bien sûr il a
réaffirmé le BIC isme et puis son
importance c'est vrai que la la majorité
relative enfin le manque de majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale met en exergue le
rôle de du Sénat qui est le représentant
des collectivités et des élus et des
territoires donc oui il est important de
pouvoir réaffirmer l'autonomie de nos
collectivités l'autonomie financière de
nos collectivités et la marge de
manœuvre et on l'a bien vu pendant les
crises le couple préfet maire on ne
cesse de parler effectivement de de nos
élus locaux de nos maire il est temps
aujourd'hui de pouvoir leur donner cette
latitude qu'ils n'ont toujours pas sous
le mon toujours pas on vient de faire
une campagne sénatoriale c'est le
message qui nous est délivré ils sont
fatigués ils en ont marre des
contraintes de la bureaucratie de le des
machines à empêcher de faire et
évidemment que ça doit être une priorité
de de la mandature qui arrive et puis
l'assemblée est paralysée Nathalie
disait l'assemblée a des difficultés est
paralysé ça veut dire que c'est chez moi
je suis depuis plus de 30 parlementaire
vous voyez c'est la première fois que je
connais une situation où le Sénat a la
main pour 2024 2027 il a la main ça veut
dire qu'il faut évidemment profiter de
cette fenêtre de tir c'est ce qu'a dit
le président comors qu'est-ce que vous
allez en faire de cette le président
Larcher vous savez Gérard Larcher c'est
un magicien du consensus donc on va
arriver à trouver des solutions il faut
réformer notre règlement il faut faire
une loi qui change pas mal de choses
dans les pouvoir d'enquête des
parlementaires et notamment des des
possibilités de territorialiser de faire
des contrôles sur pièces et sur place
pour chaque sénateur dans son
département donc renforcer le rôle de
contrôle et évidemment débloquer
légiférer moins et légiférit mieux ouais
c'est ce qu'il a dit hein ça c'est aussi
la deuxième phrase qu'on peut retenir il
nous faut moins légiférer pour mieux
légiférer mais il a dit ça s'adresse au
gouvernement mais ça s'adresse aussi au
parlementaires est-ce qu'il y a trop de
proposition de aussi écoutez moi j'ai
Nathalie de latreussi on est souvent
rapporteur de de projet de loi et on
voit bien que certains de nos collègues
ont tendance à faire trop d'amendements
et et que on serait bien plus efficient
si on essayait de regrouper un certain
nombre de choses et trop de propositions
de loi ça vaut peut-être aussi non non
les propositions de loi sont tout à fait
utiles c'est c'est quand le gouvernement
pêche vous voulez que je vous donne un
exemple moi j'ai fait une proposition de
loi sur la reconnaissance facial parce
que je considère que les risques c'est
pas moi qui le dit le procureur
antiterroriste les risques de d'attentat
sont patents sur les Jeux Olympiques et
donc il faut qu'on ait pour une période
déterminée et dans des conditions très
encadrées la possibilité de de déjouer
les les risques terroristes et bien nous
avons voté une proposition largement ici
au Sénat et le gouvernement l'a toujours
pas reprise à ce jour une proposition de
loi j'ai été l'auteur de la proposition
de loi des agressions contre les élus je
crois que c'est pas superflu au
contraire non je crois que les
propositions de loi sont pertinentes
nous avons trop de projets de loi du
gouvernement je pense qu'il faut
effectivement qu'il prennent le temps de
faire des lois qui soient suffisamment
mû c'est vrai que nous le voyons le
pouvoir du Sénat s'est exprimé depuis
quelques mois depuis quelques années là
avec la commission mixte paritaire ce
pouvoir de la commission mixte paritaire
dont nous
sommes pour moitié responsable et bien
nous voyons bien que nous arrivons à à
rendre ces ces projets lois plus
pertinents plus impactant je pense que
c'est là aussi qu'il y a une marge de
progression et on le rappelle pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous écoutent un
projet de loi ça vient du gouvernement
une proposition de loi ça vient des
parlementaires pour que ça soit clair
pour tout le monde un dernier mot
peut-être sur le discours de Gérard
Larcher puisqu'il a parlé de la
modification de la Constitution notre
Constitution ne se modifie pas en
fonction des pulsion du moment s'il faut
faire attention notamment vous vous avez
des propositions chez les républicains
de modifier la Constitution sur la
question de l'immigration pour rendre
possible le référendum qu'est-ce que
vous pensez du coup de cette phrase et
ben pas seulement ce qu'a dit Gérard
Larché c'est qu'il faut pas faire des
propositions de politique politicienne
mais mais des modifications
constitutionnelles qui rendent des
choses possible aujourd'hui le Conseil
constitutionnel nous recale par exemple
la proposition de Nathalie del lat pour
et et j'en ai fait une aussi on en a
fait ensemble pour alourdir les peines
contre les violences faites aux élus
locaux elle a été bloquée au Conseil
constitutionnel pour une raison de
cavalier législatif c'est-à-dire pour
vos téléspectateurs que elle n'était pas
complètement dans l'ordonnancement de la
du projet de loi du gouvernement il faut
qu'on puisse changer tout ça le
Parlement fait la loi et donc quelque
part il faut qu'on puisse améliorer les
choses mais pas pour faire de la
politique politicienne trafiquer les
modes de scrutin ou les bah par exemple
et donc on a fait nos propositions
depuis longtemps le président de la
République les connaît on pourra faire
une réforme constitutionnelle si le le
président vient sur nos propositions et
pas le contraire évidemment il en faut
quand même une de réforme
constitutionnelle écoutez en tout cas il
faut qu'elle corresponde à une attente
profonde de la population dire que
effectivement réagir toujours par
rapport à l'actualité par par rapport à
des demandes fluctuante je pense que
c'est pas ce quiattend la population je
pense qu'aujourd'hui la population sent
nos concitoyens sentent euh qu'il y a
des réformes nécessaires mais souhait en
comprendre la portée et participer aussi
à à cette décision à ce sens de
l'histoire on va passer au second thème
de ce débat on va parler de la sécurité
dans les zones rurales comment améliorer
la sécurité dans les zones rurales
Emmanuel Macron était hier dans le
lotgaron pour dévoiler la carte des 230
nouvell brigad de gendarmerie regarde ça
avec Jonathan
dupriaaz du bleu partout voilà
l'ambition affichée par le Président de
la République pour répondre à
l'insécurité en visite dans le loté
Garon Emmanuel Macron a dévoilé la carte
des 238 nouvelles brigades de
gendarmerie fixé mobile qui verront le
jour d'ici à 2027 un réinvestissement
que le chef de l'État qualifie
d'historique je pense que c'est c'est
surtout une réponse à l'insécurité au
phénomène qu'il y a et c'est comme ça
que je regarde les choses mais c'est
d'abord
un moyen objectif parce que ça s'est
fait aussi avec un très gros travail de
la gendarmerie qui a regardé l'évolution
de la délinquence des dernières années
son évolution à venir c'est ce sont des
besoins c'est donc il y a un critère
d'objectivité de dialogue très local qui
s'est fait cet effort doit permettre de
compenser en partie la suppression de
500 brigades intervenues entre 2007 et
2016 sur le territoire à cela s'ajoute
la création de 2100 postes de gendarmes
d'ici à la fin du quinquena à travers
ses annonces Emmanuel Macron veut
prouver qu'il peut-être un président des
territoires à la tête d'un État qui se
réengage pour la ruralité tout ce que je
veux vous dire c'est qu'on est au côté
de la ruralité et c'est qu'il y a pas de
fatalité qu'il s'agisse de la sécurité
qu'il s'agisse de la santé qu'il
s'agisse de l'écologie ou de l'école il
y a juste à nous mobiliser tous ensemble
le gouvernement investit sur chacun de
ces sujets je remercie tous les
fonctionnaires nos élus s'investisent de
manière incroyable et on va tous y
arriver ces annonces sur la sécurité
arrivent dans un contexte particulier 3
mois après les é urbaine qui ont vu le
pays s'embraser après la mort du jeune
Naël à
Nanterre 238 nouvelles brigades de
gendarmerie Marc Philippe debress c'est
plus que la promesse initiale de
campagne du président répartie sur
l'ensemble du territoire vous saluez
cette annonce bah écoutez on a coproduit
la loi lopmi la loi d'orientation des
moyens du ministère de l'Intérieur j'en
étais le rapporteur et plusieurs de nos
collègues y ont largement contribué et
donc évidemment qu'on n'est pas contre
le fait de mettre plus de moyens 25 % de
moyens en plus pour lutter aussi contre
la cybersécurité très bien sauf que euh
le problème majeur c'est l'organisation
des forces de l'ordre aujourd'hui 37 %
seulement des forces de l'ordre sont sur
le terrain il faut redéployer sur le
terrain et notamment dans les zones
rurales qui sont très fragilisées c'est
ce qu'on a dit dans dans la loi et on a
fait adopter un amendement on a fait
adopter un amendement qui oblige le
gouvernement à concerter les élus locaux
département par département pour savoir
où et et comment faut-il mettre des
brigades mobiles ou fixes et à quel
endroit dans les départements donc quand
même il y a un rôle du Sénat major dans
cette affaire mais ça va pas résoudre
pour autant les problèmes de délinquence
sur le fond on va y revenir mais sur le
l'annonce bah c'est l'application d'une
loi d'orientation que nous avons voté
oui tout à fait c'était nécessaire nous
l'avions souligné il faut plus de moyens
sur le le territoire la Gironde par
exemple plus grand département de France
6e population française c'est 41000
crimes et délit et 97 % du territoire
est en zone de gendarmerie donc il
fallait effectivement ses renforts
depuis 6 ans on avait eu 250 gendarmes
de plus là nous avons eu l'annonce de
trois gendarmeries fixes trois
gendarmeries deux gendarmeries fixes et
une mobile c'était nécessaire parce
qu'on le voit on commence à gagner la
bataille de la délinquence de
l'appropriation c'est-à-dire une
stabilisation des vols des cambriolages
bon c'est relative par cette présence
mais on a encore énormément de travail
sur les violences fait aux personnes
violence intrafamiliale violence
maintenant aux élus les rodéos la
circulation routière donc on voit bien
que là c'est vraiment de la police de
proximité qu'il nous faut et la zone
rurale il fallait doter cette zone
rurale de moyens supplémentaires ouais
Emmanuel Macron l'a dit hier on a un
problème de sécurité dès lors qu'il n'y
a pas de présence c'est important de
remettre cette présence sur le terrain
oui évidemment c'est important mais
c'est comme quand on a annoncé il y a
quelques années la police de proximité
ça ne suffit pas le sujet majeur
aujourd'hui c'est pas la police ni la
gendarmerie c'est la justice et donc
quand nous nous proposons dans dans la
fameuse loi lopmi qu'on puisse
sanctionner doubler les sanctions sur
les refus d'obtempérés on voit où on en
est aujourd'hui sur les rodéos urbains
ou sur les violences faites aux élus en
particulier avec la proposition de
Madame de Lat qui était tout à fait
pertinente et bien on nous recale les
choses et puis on n dit allez voir dans
la loi justice on redépose nos
amendements dans la loi de justice on
dit ah non c'est une réforme du code de
procédure pénale et pas du code pénal
comment voulez-vous que les Français s
retrouve et les maires se sentent
impuissants parce qu'on leur on les
empêche d'agir d'un côté et et de
l'autre côté on a plein c'est la
violence qui monte le problème de la
délinquence aujourd'hui c'est la montée
de la violence et de la drogue dans tous
nos quartiers et donc il faut adapter
les choses ce qui suppose d'avoir une
réforme profonde de la justice
excusez-moi de le dire qui n'a pas eu
lieu à ce jour donc ça veut dire que
c'estes 238 nouvelles brigades de
gendarmerie elles vont évidemmentont pas
efficac si la
jus servir à tranquilliser la population
madame de lâre l'a dit à baisser sans
doute les cambriolages ou les homejcking
ou les carjcking mais elles ne vont pas
résoudre le problème de la violence en
particulier intrafamilial et donc il
faut absolument avoir des réponses
judiciaires des réponses pénales les
questions des mineurs tout ce qui s'est
passé pendant les émeutes et ça
excusez-moi pour l'instant la copie
n'est pas pertinente de la part du
gouvernement ou je partage complètement
c'est vrai qu'effectivement on met les
moyens sur le terrain à un moment donné
je le vois bien regardez en Gironde où
la prison de de Gradignan est saturée
nous avons besoin d'équipement
supplémentaires parce que effectivement
à un moment donné la police la
gendarmerie fait son travail qui est
souvent de pouvoir faire de de mettre de
côté des personnes dangereuses et bien
il n'y a pas de possibilité pas pas
assez de de de matériel pas assez de de
bracelets antiapprochement par exemple
pour les violences intrafamiliales donc
on sait très bien que dans les prisons
il trop de personnes donc on les laisse
en liberté donc effectivement la suite
logique et de parvenir maintenant à
réformer cette justice et ce qu'on on va
s'y employer pour cette mandature on a
fait des propositions de loi ladessus ah
ben on sait on on attend la suite la
délinquence rurale euh est-ce que vous
constatez qu'elle est en augmentation
pour vous parler de Natalie DEAT des
violences intrafamiliales en 2021 les
forces de l'ordre ont localisé dans les
communes rurales près du quart des
violences sexuelles et intrafamilial ou
des cambriolages enregistrés il y a un
déplacement de l'indélinquence
aujourd'hui dans le rural ben il y a
d'autant plus un déplac placement par
exemple nous nous avons un essort
démographique 20000 habitants par an
supplémentair qui viennent effectivement
dans la métropole en zone police
nationale mais après pour moitié sur le
Bassin d'Arcachon et et sur le les zones
rurales donc bien évidemment nous avons
une augmentation mécanique puisqueune
partie de la population c'est ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure 55 % de la
population maintenant en zone rurale
donc il y a ce phénomène de déplacement
et puis cette délinquence juvellille
c'est vrai que on a des enfants qui par
les trafics de drogues notamment sont
amené à faire de plus en plus de de de
de de commèes de plus en plus de de de
délit et et malheureusement aussi en
zone rurale on a le même phénomène dans
la métropole lilloise et on a le même
phénomène dans les zones frontalières
c'est-à-dire que il y a de la
délinquence qui vient du pays voisin en
l'occurence chez nous la Belgique et et
et les trafics de drogue alimentent tout
ça et donc pour passer les frontières
tranquillement bah on passe souvent par
les zones rurales d'où l'importance de
créer on l'avait dit pendant le débat
des brigades mobiles pas seulement des
brigades fixes parce que j'attire aussi
votre attention qu'entre le moment où on
décide d'implanter la gendarmerie et où
on a construit la caserne et où on peut
loger les gendarmes il y a un problème
parce qu'il y a une grande crise du
logement faudra qu'on en reparle un jour
parce que ça va aller très très très mal
on va parler mais là vous demandiez des
brigades mobiles sur les 238 il y a 93 F
fixes et 145 mobiles ça veut dire que le
le présidentend par brigade m ça c'est
une bonne
décision et nous l'avions inspiré
pendant le débat làdessus c'est bien qui
est des brigades mobiles Emmanuel Macron
dit ça va permettre d'aller dans les
territoires des laessé ah oui mais c'est
pertinent on voit bien que il y a besoin
de renfort sur certains territoires à
certains moments quand effectivement il
y a l'arrivée de de nouvelles
populations un déplacement de de
population ça va permettre d'être
beaucoup plus pragmatique ça va
permettre aussi vous le savez moi je me
bat de depuis longtemps pour maintenir
nos effectifs de mettre nageur sauveteur
CRS sur les plages parce qu'il nous faut
des gens qui ont une maturité qui ont
une connaissance effectivement de de
leur
métier et aussi la possibilité on voit
la délinquence sur les plages a énormé
énormément augmenté les violences sur
les plages ont énormément augmenté sont
des personnels qui peuvent avoir leurs
armes et qui peuvent faire de la
dissuasion aussi donc c'est important de
de continuer il va falloir poursuivre
c'était aussi une demande marf vous
sortez vous d'une campagne sénatoriale
vous av j'ai du littoral ouais mais vous
avez aussi rencontré beaucoup de gens
c'était une demande ça d'avoir plus de
bleus sur le terrain sûr bien sûr
évidemment et et et je je dis aussi par
exemple nous nous avions proposé qu'on
puisse utiliser des drones encadrés avec
un rôle de de gendarme de la de laacnil
mais qu'on puisse utiliser des nouveaux
moyens parce que prenez le littoral
Landis ou prenez est le littoral de la
côte d'Opal on a ces problèmes là et on
a des passages qui viennent de la
Belgique en particulier pour des trafic
de drogue et on a le problème des
migrants qui aussi et donc utiliser des
nouvelles technologies et bien le
Conseil constitutionnel pour parti nous
recale là-dessus c'est pas possible
qu'on continue comme ça il faut
absolument qu'on affirme une capacité de
résoudre des problèmes on a des
solutions mais on est recalé souvent
pour des questions juridiques et il faut
changer tout ça rapidement ouais c'était
c'était une demande ça aussi des des
frçais ce besoin de plus de gendarmes
sur le terrain de voir des gendarmes
plus sur le terrain Natalie oui parce
qu'il y a un sentiment d'insécurité qui
n'est pas qu'un sentiment la plupart du
temps il y a de
l'insécurité bien évidemment donc oui
les français demandent à être rassurés
protéger c'est essentiel pour notre vie
démocratique ouais Emmanuel Macron dit
que c'est un réinvestissement historique
il y a 500 brigades qui ont été supprimé
entre 2007 et 2016 est-ce qu'il y a eu
des erreurs notamment de la part de la
droite au-delà de la magie sa
communication il y ait pas d'illusion de
l'action vous voyez et pour l'instant
euh il y a quand même problème dans
l'action parce que on annonce beaucoup
de choses et que ça met du temps à venir
sauf que là il a recréé des postes là où
vous en aviez suprimé on a voté une loi
de programmation vous savez j'était
ministre délégué à la cohésion sociale
chez Jean-Louis borlot et quand on vote
une loi de programmation sur 5 ans la
première année ça se passe souvent très
bien faut vérifier que les années
suivantes budgétairement on s'en sort et
vous voyez ce que Monsieur le Maire est
en train de faire en ce moment il est en
train de couper toute une série de
crédits budgétaires ça va poser
d'ailleurs de gros problèmes parce que
il a laissé le quoi qu'il en coûte
dépenser mais pas sur la création des
postes de de forces de l'ordre parce que
je vois bien que vous voulez pas me
répondre là-dessus mais est-ce que
quelque part il y a besoin de compenser
ce qui a été Suppr demander qu'on
sanctuarise ses crédits parce que ce
sont des lois de programmation qui
doivent se faire sur 5 ans et Madame bne
à l'époque a dit tout le monde dans le
même panier non non non on doit pas
réagir comme ça nous à l'époque avec
borlau on avait réussi à sanctuariser
nos crédits par le prés président Chirac
il faut la même chose sur un certain
nombre de priorités et on a la justice
et la police qui de mon point de vue
sont deux priorités et vous CZ que ça
soit pas sanctuarisé je je veux regarder
avec attention les les années suivantes
de la loi de programmation je connais
trop Bery et sa capacité à couper les
têtes Nathalie Z vous partagez cette
inquiétude ou pas en tout cas ce qui est
important c'est qu'on a un ministre de
l'Intérieur qui qui tient tête et qui
effectivement bat se bat pour pouvoir
conserver ses moyens indpensable et qui
a un dialogue constant avec les élus
locaux et c'est par cette volonté des
élus locaux effectivement que le
ministre de l'Intérieur arrivera aussi à
sanctuariser ses crédits mais quand même
quand il y a 3500 gendarmes en plus sur
le terrain ce qu'a dit le chef de l'État
2100 plus avec ses nouvelles brigades
quement rassurer la population et ça va
faire de diminuer le sentiment
d'insécurité mais ça ne s'attaque pas à
une nouvelle je je critique pas le
gouvernement en tant que tel il y a une
nouvelle cause de la délinquence très
grave qui s'appelle la violence et il y
a une montée exponentielle de la drogue
donc si vous faites une montée
importante des moyens avec une montée
exponentiel vous ne n'arrivez toujours
pas à à régler le fond du problème et je
vous le redis le fond du problème il
font pas asse parce que hier Emmanuel
Macron a dit on pilone tous les points
de D on laisse personne au repos il en
fait pas assez le gouvernement P dans la
lutte contre la drogue la police fait
son travail elle le fait très bien
d'ailleurs elle est très fatiguée je
peux vous le dire j'ai deux brigades de
CR chez moi ils sont exténués elle fait
très bien mais derrière quand on pilon
les points de Deal et que la réponse
pénale ou judiciaire c'est tu le feras
plus mon petit excusez-moi il y a un
sujet et c'est bien le sujet de la
réponse pénale qui doit être traité en
priorité aujourd'hui donc pas de la
lutte l'action du gouvernement sur la
lutte contre la drogue Nathalie delatra
elle est suffisante c'est la bonne
écoutez en tout cas quand on regarde et
on se compare dans le monde entier
c'est un trafic très compliqué avec des
enjeux supérieur pour pour certains donc
une loi de tout est possible euh et
effectivement mais c'est très difficile
pour l'ensemble des dirigeants de de
combattre ce fléo alors c'est vrai que
la réponse est dans la justice mais il y
a aussi un accompagnement santé euh et
là aussi on doit avoir les moyens on le
sait la santé mentale des jeunes est
précaire euh c'est vrai que du coup ils
vont aller se réfugier euh sur des
produits qui peuvent les rassurer mais
qui vont les détruire malheureusement
donc il faut beaucoup communiquer et à
côté de de la police la justice il faut
aussi que l'on mette les moyens en santé
Emmanuel Macron il aa pas choisi le
lotgaron au hasard pour faire ses
annonces c'est un territoire qui a voté
Marine Le Pen est-ce que annoncer ces
nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie c'est
aussi un moyen de lutter contre le
rassemblement national Marc Philip
doobess bah écoutez le problème du
rassemblement national c'est qu' vit du
malheur des gens si vous voulez il
prospère plus plus il y a de malheur et
plus il y a de difficultés dans la
société ou de risque d'explosion sociale
et nous y sommes en particulier avec la
crise du logement et plus le le le
assemblement national il prospère sur le
problème des gens il résout pas les
problèmes des gens et au contraire il
les aliment pour que ils puissent
prospérer donc évidemment que tout
annonce qui va dans le sens d'aller plus
vite et mieux dans la lutte contre les
gros problèmes de la population en
particulier la délinquence va dans le
bon sens sur un plan politique mais je
pense pas que ce soit la première
priorité de cette annonce et ça peut pas
faire baisser une rassemblement national
Nathalie delâre est-ce que c'est ça
c'est une réponse aux Français qui qui
votent pour le rassemblement national il
en faudrait plusieurs réponses il y a
effectivement la sécurité moi je ne
cesse de dénoncer les chaînes d'opinion
je je préfèreit conserver des bonnes
chaînes d'information on sait
qu'effectivement les mécanismes de
populisme sont
aussi perpétré par la par les images
qu'on peut voir cette insécurité qu'on
peut voir en permanence et qui vient
dans dans son intimité donc oui il
faudrait continuer en tout cas à avoir
des annonces euh pour faire en sorte que
cette menace populiste puisse s'éloigner
c'est-à-dire sur d'autres plans pas
uniquement sur cette question de sécité
oui oui il y a beaucoup d'autres
d'autres politiques à mener sur
l'ensemble de ce qui touche les les
Français notamment sur le logement Marc
Philippe de vous nous le disiez mais
encore on va connaître c'est l'ancien
ministre du logement qui vous le dit une
crise historique sans précédent du
logement environ 200 à 250000
disparitions de postes dans le bâtiment
l'an prochain et le gouvernement ne fait
rien moi ça fait 3 ans qu'avec mes
collègue Dominique Estrosi avec beaucoup
de collègues d'autres groupes politiques
nous disons attention on on va dans le
mur et Monsieur Macron avec qui j'ai
discuté une demi-heure dans une
cérémonie patriotique m'a écouté
posément mais il ne nous a pas entendu
il considère que ça va réguler le marché
pas du tout parce qu'on a une crise de
l'offre et de la demande en même temps
avec la montée des taux d'intérêt ça
touche évidemment le pouvoir d'achat
c'est le premier poste de dépenses des
ménages aujourd'hui et ça va exploser
socialement je vous le dis moi j'ai moi
qui ai vécu les émeutes de 2005 je vous
dis que nous sommes au bord d'une
explosion sociale les les Français n'en
peuvent plus il faut une réponse très
rapide sur les problèmes du logement
c'est une réponse fiscale une réponse de
de financement les taux d'intérêt et une
réponse sur le foncier et il y a pas de
plan Marshal à l'horizon et donc ça va
exploser vraiment et donc ça va
alimenter toute cette machine
d'impuissance publique et donc quelque
part la montée derrière du rassemblement
national not vous crinez une bombe
sociale
sur cette question philiip lui-même le
dit je reprends son
expression non mais voilà c'est c'est un
constat partagé on ne cesse de le
dénoncer ici dans l'hémicycle du du
Sénat pourquoi parce que nos élus locaux
sur le territoire le vivent euh il y a
une peur
euh qui de la part des Français de ne
plus avoir un toit parce que
effectivement il y a les les
propriétaires mais l'inflation fait que
ce poste logement devient prépondérant
euh dans les dépenses des ménages et
puis vous le savez il y a eu des
recompositions de de famille pour un
enfant il faut de logement euh et donc
effectivement ça fragilise il y a des
des des familles en grande fragilité des
besoins des demandes et pour l'instant
effectivement nous ne sommes pas au
compte on revient sur cette question de
la sécurité et de la délinquence comme
sur beaucoup de sujets les maires sont
souvent en première ligne et on a
constaté une augmentation des violences
envers les élus la semaine prochaine le
Sénat va examiner un texte sur la
sécurité des élus le gouvernement a fait
des annonces euh déjà sur ce sujet est
ce qu' vons dans le bon sens Nathalie
mais bien sûr que ça va dans le bon sens
mais encore une fois évidemment nous
avons là de de de la communication
ensuite il faut avoir le temps qu'elle
se décline sur le le territoire euh on
parlait effectivement de de la
gendarmerie il y a aujourd'hui des
référents dans la gendarmerie euh qui
sont l'interface des élus il y a encore
peu euh il y avait beaucoup de
classements sans suite de plaintes d'élu
quand les plaintes étaient enregistrées
donc ce dialogue va pouvoir permettre
d'améliorer la situation des élus mais
il faut ne pas se cacher les élus en
parlait peu avant donc on a pu faire
avec notamment cette loi un Mitou de de
de la des des élus qui ont pu parler
enfin et se libérer libérer leurs
paroles parce qu'ils considérer que ça
faisait partie de la fonction non se
faire agresser n'est pas normal ne fait
pas partie de la fonction d'un élu donc
voilà le gouvernement met en place ses
référents il y a encore beaucoup de
choses à faire mais effectivement en la
matière il y a encore beaucoup d'annonce
à à avoir parce que c'est Don la réponse
pénale je sais ce que vous allez me dire
Mar Philip de j'étais 29 an mer j'ai été
agressé et et il a été condamné mon
agresseur qui avait 12 whiskis dans le
sang et bien il a toujours pas eu le le
début d'une condamnation c'était il y a
un peu plus de 11 ans enfit il a
toujours pas eu un début d'exécution des
peines pardon c'était il y a un peu plus
de 11 ans et puis j'en ai un autre qui a
eu 30 37 fois un rappel à l'ordre c'est
pas possible de continuer comme ça il
faut vraiment une eff vous vous allez au
Canada par exemple vous avez une réponse
efficiente dans le moi qui suit et
souvent je parle pas des viols et des
crimes bien évidemment mais pour les
délit les petits délits ou les
agressions de ce type vous avez des
travaux d'intérêts généraux vous avez
des réponses immédiates et ça va très
vite et la contestation juridique peut
se faire après et je pense qu'il faut
s'inspirer de ce modèle qui est à la
fois efficace à l'américaine et
humaniste à la française un dernier mot
Nathalie delâre on sent monter hein
évidemment le le ralbol des élus le
ralbol des mères est-ce que euh vous
craignez une grande démission une crise
d'évocation pour 2026 écoutez c'est vrai
que euh les sénateurs qui ont fait
campagne nous disent que ça a été
compliqué difficile euh et je pense
qu'effectivement pour nous euh l'autre
moitié qui sommes renouvellement pour
2026 nous allons effectivement avoir une
multiplication de ces problématique avec
un un personnel politique qui
effectivement est fatigué va être
renouvelé je pense que l'on on arrivera
encore à trouver des vocations c'est
pour ça qu'il faut agir il faut
préserver les fondements de notre
République il faut effectivement
garantir aux élus qu'ils pourront
exercer leur mandat dans les meilleures
condition possible que ça soit de
sécurité ou d'autonomie financière c'est
la seule condition pour que notre
République tienne vous l'avez senti sera
le bol des mer sur le terrain j'ai
rencontré plusieurs centaines de d'élus
locaux dans ma campagne au moins un sur
qu m'a dit je j'en ai marre je vais pas
me représenter et c'est la lassitude
devant l'impuissance publique et leur
incapacité à pouvoir agir concrètement
alors qu'ils ont été les premiers
remparts face à la au gilets jaune ou
dans le ou dans la l'épidémie de covid
et il est grand temps de reconnaître
l'action majeure des él lu de proximité
on va parler de ces brigades de
gendarmerie puisque ça fait la une de la
presse régionale ce matin on voit tout
de suite ça avec
[Musique]
Alex et Alex à la une de la presse
régionale donc la création de ces plus
de 200 nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie
et oui Orian de nombreux journaux
régionaux consacrent leur une aux 238
nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie qui
ont été dévoilé hier par Emmanuel Macron
dans le lotégaron chaque quotidien
régional s'intéresse en fait aux
brigades qui vont être créé dans leur
territoire alors ces brigades seront
fixes ou mobiles elles vont renforcer le
maillage territorial des forces de
l'ordre à l'horizon de 2027 l'objectif
c'est de rendre davantage visible les
gendarmes dans les territoires ruraux et
je cite le chef de l'État qui a assuré
hier que les gens avaient besoin de
cette présence des forces de l'ordre car
car elle rassure elle dissuade et elle
accompagne C cet effort vise aussi à
compenser les 500 brigades suprémées
entre 2007 et 2016 à la Une de de la
voie du Nord et toujours sur le thème de
la sécurité des lycées ont reçu des
menaces d'attentat à roubet tourcoin et
vatrelot sur l'espace numérique de
travail des parents et enseignants ont
reçu des menaces en rapport à
l'interdiction de laaba à l'école le
lycée Colbert de tourcoin a été fermé
les autres sont étroitement surveillés
et ratissés par des équipes de des
mineurs accompagné de chiens certains
parents ne veulent plus envoyer leurs
enfants dans les lycées concernés un
petit mot Mar debr c'est votre
territoire surprise notamment sur le
territoire de roubet tourcoin que
connaît bien Gérald daranaa nous avons
des des des mouvements salafiste qui
existe et nous avons évidemment un
combat qui est contre cette affirmation
de la laïcité dans nos établissement moi
je reste partisan du port de l'uniforme
dans les établissements qui me semblent
la meilleure réponse pour garantir la
laïcité tout en garantissant la liberté
de religion on redescend dans le sud à
la Une de La Dépêche du Midi la flambée
des prix du mutuel des prix des mutuels
oui et oui les tarifs des
complémentaires santé se sont envolés en
2023 selon l'association UFC Que Choisir
la hausse moyenne des mutuelles s'élève
à 7,1 % cette année soit un surcût
médian de 126 € par an comment
l'expliquer et bien les technologies de
santé de point de cooutûteuse le
vieillissement de la population et aussi
la réforme du 100 % santé qui a étendu
la prise en charge des soins dentaires
auditifs et optiques et augmenté la part
de remboursement des complémentaires
parmi les départements où les mutuels
augmentent le plus l'Île-de-France - de
France et les Alpes Maritimes et puis
les seniors sont plus spécifiquement
touchés on finit par cor ce matin qui
fait sa Une sur un jeune champion du
monde d'échec et oui un jeune Corse âgé
de 16 ans sacré champion du monde
d'échec des moins de 20 ans c'était le
weekend dernier à Mexico Marc Andria
moridzi a l'habitude des médailles dans
ce sport à 10 ans il était champion du
monde d'Europe d'échec de sa catégorie à
12 ans mître international d'échec à 14
ans grand maître international c'est le
plus jeune français de l'histoire à
avoir cette distinction donc peut- nouau
trouve sur l'île de Beauté mie
l'intelligence artificielle voilà on
suivra tout ça merci Mar Philippe debr
merci Natalie d'avoir été notre invité
merci al merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi à 18h vous avez rendez-vous avec
Thas pour sens public et n on se
retrouve demain très bonne
journée